لمونديال لاعب كره القدم طابع خاص الكل
يتابع وان لم تكن اهتماماته رياضيه فكره
انا منتخب البلديه يلعب في المحفل العالمي
وليس النادي تثير طبعا مشاعر وطنيه للكل
المشجعون الايرانيون بكم مثلا خلال عزفي
النشيد الوطني لبلادهم الاحتجاجات وسوء
الاوضاعف البلاد مضاعفات المشاعرهم
واحاسيسهم ببلادهم والمشاعر ذاتها عند
اللاعبين لكن طريقه التعبير مختلفه لم
يرددوا النشيد دعما للاحتجاجات في
المباراه الاولى ورددوها في الثانيه قد
يتم اعتقالهم بسبب الامر رغم انهم يرددوه
في المباراه الثانيه
قد يحدث بالفعل لانه حصل قبل لاعب في فريق
كره بتهمه التحريض ضد النظام سوريا غفوري
ينحدر من سندس يعني اكبر مدينه كرديه في
ايران مسقط راس مساء
اذا السياسه ليست ببعيده عن الكره ولا
المونديال في كاس العالم مع عام
1974 لم يحصل لاعبوا زئير او الكونغو
الديمقراطيه حاليا على مكافات الفيفا
النظام اخدها غضب وقرروا التغيب عن
المباراه الثانيه ليفاجا بمكالمه امن
الرئيس ساحضر المباراه واراقب ما اذا كنتم
ستدخلون ارض الملعب ام لا التهديد بالطبعا
جعلهم يلعبون في نفس المونديال لكن في
تصفياته الضحى الاتحاد
في الفنا 1906 و60 مونديال انجلترا
الاخيره كان قرارها الرفض طلب تاشيرات
منتخب دوله تراها غير شرعيه كوريا
الشماليه قبل ان يرداها تحذير الفيفا دوله
اخرى ستنظم كاس العالم تراجع
الجمهور الانجليزيه بنفسه وتحديدا في
مدرسه برو تعاطف مع منتخب كوريا الشماليه
ليس سياسيا بسبب الاداء مفاجاه تحدثنا
عنها بالامس هزمت كوريا الشماليه ايطاليا
يعني بتحتفل بهذا الجيل السنويا لمده 30
عاما نجاحنا ان لم يتكرر في عام 2010
عندما قطعت سلطات اول بث حي لمباراه كره
قدم بعد تلقي الفريق لاربعه اهداف
البرتغاليه